across the u.s supermarkets are again
experiencing supply shortages of such
basic goods as milk eggs and other
household items a wave of omicron cases
global supply chain issues labor
shortages and extreme weather are being
blamed for the lack of goods another
contributing factor the trucking
industry some 70 percent of goods
delivered in the us are by road the main
lobbying group for the trucking company
says it needs an extra 80 000 new
drivers to get goods where they need to
be and to help meet the demand for
drivers people as young as 18 could soon
be allowed to drive trucks into state
after completing a federal
apprenticeship program four decades ago
in 1980 deregulation turned much of the
trucking industry into what we now call
the gig economy drivers are not paid for
the time on the job but for miles
travels they basically give the company
that you're going to deliver to or pick
up from
they give them two hours free
to sit there and do whatever they need
to do the driver doesn't get paid many
truckers are classified as independent
contractors not employees so companies
don't pay for the upkeep of their trucks
or invest in truck stops or warehouses a
trucker drives the allotted legal time
and then stops wherever they are you get
after five six o'clock especially here
on the east coast five o'clock
you might be on the side of the road
somewhere trying to find a spot
is if there is a shortage there has been
a steep decline in wages for truckers
between 1977 and 1987 trucker
compensation fell by some 35 percent the
average trucker salary is now around 50
000 a year
but there is another stock statistic
trucking has an overall job turnover
rate of between 74 and 92 percent that
is between seven and nine out of ten
drivers leave their jobs after a year we
reached out to the american truckers
association but they declined to speak
to us but the u.s census in fact shows a
record number of qualified truck drivers
in the u.s that's why others say the
problem lies elsewhere there is no
shortage of truck drivers in the united
states and in fact we have a surplus of
drivers we have millions of people in
the u.s who've trained to become a truck
driver and then decided not to do the
job dr vicelli says the trucking
industry has used the same tactics since
deregulation in 1980 to insist on
further deregulation so that it can have
as many workers to choose from as
possible that way it can offer the least
wages and benefits while maximizing its
profits simply lowering the driving age
is is not going to make things better it
burns them out most people won't last
won't last six months something we've
heard throughout this supply chain
crisis is that it's decades of
deregulation that focused on corporate
profits instead of building
infrastructure like truck depots for
example and taking care of workers that
got us here sri abertancy al jazeera
maryland